joining us now is David Shone former
Trump impeachment lawyer
David
um hearing arraignment and former
president together in the same sentence
I mean I'm not at all surprised about
this because I do believe they will do
anything in their power to stop Donald
Trump from having the possibility of
being the GOP nominee and defeating Joe
Biden or whoever the Democrat nominee is
uh so this doesn't surprise me at all
but how far out over skis is brag on the
legal aspect of this any American who
even considers the idea that Mr Bragg
could indict president Trump ought to be
outraged it's a strike at the rule of
law it's a strike at our Constitution
and the fact that anyone could be
talking about an indictment or an
arraignment after Bob Costello's
testimony today is even more than
outrageous the grand jury had to hear
exculpatory and impeachment evidence the
prosecutor had an obligation to present
that until Bob Costello testified today
they hadn't heard that Bob Costello's
testimony is qualitatively a material
materially different from anything
they've heard Cohen spoke to him as a
lawyer he Co Bob Costello has 330 email
exchanges Bob Costello spoke in detail
about what what Mr Cohen told him that's
diametrically opposed to the story that
he's telling now and what's most telling
about it is apparently according to Bob
the D.A said that they didn't know these
things they met some 20 times or so with
Mr Cohen and they didn't know that he
had spoken with Bob Costello that Bob
Costello had done a debriefing with the
U.S attorney's Office this opens all
kinds of floodgates they must demand
notes from the U.S attorney's Office Bob
Costello is the former deputy chief of
the southern district of New York U.S
attorney's office he was represented in
the debriefings by the former Chief of
the Criminal Division in the southern
district he's entitled to Great
credibility and they only heard from him
begrudgingly they only let the grand
jury hear six of his 330 emails and he
had to continually keep telling the
story about what he knew they had eight
prosecutors in there they didn't want
the grand jury to hear the truth
they didn't they didn't want to hear
from him at all he volunteered to go
into the grand jury and this is what it
was this was at the 11th Hour apparently
I mean first it was former president
Trump's going to be arraigned uh
tomorrow indicted tomorrow now they're
pushing it off till next week it seems
like they're enjoying this you know the
drag out of this again more distraction
from Biden's failures across the board
but the statutes themselves if I could
just go to the statutes sure that's
perhaps they would be leaning on here
can you explain why these are absurd in
this case uh that's 175.05 first
absolutely absurd 175.05 makes it a
misdemeanor with the intent to defraud
to falsify business records first of all
I don't believe that business records
were falsified but secondly with the
intent to fraud and what they want to do
here is use a novel Theory not just to
bring an indictment against an ordinary
person but against the president of the
United States unprecedented makes it a
felony under 175.10 the New York penal
law if you committed the falsified
business records with the intent of
Fraud and you did it to try to conceal
or commit another crime which they say
here is well he did it to conceal a
campaign contribution he did it to
affect the campaign did Hillary Clinton
make a campaign contribution when she
paid someone to bust up her computers
without a campaign contribution there
are so many facts that so many facts
here beyond all of that there's a reason
we in the law have a statute of
limitations and in New York a five-year
statute of limitations for a felony
Witnesses aren't around anymore people's
stories change and all that these
allegations are more than seven or seven
years old they will re reviewed and
rejected by the southern district of New
York most prominent office in the
country by the Federal Election
Commission so why Mr Bragg now because
president Trump is up in the polls
because Mr Bragg campaigned on an
anti-trump I'm going to get Trump
campaign since 2020. I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what he's doing uh Bragg
wants to run for governor that's what I
believe I think this is about Bragg and
his future in politics he's the first
African-American in this role and I
think he wants to take this all the way
to the governor's mansion that's what I
think this is about maybe who knows run
for president someday it's all about Dr
Bob Costello today gave him an out to
save face once and for all and back off
of this and say we didn't know these
things now that we know them we cannot
go forward with Michael Cohen as the key
to this case yeah I don't they're too
far in I don't think they're going to
back off but maybe I'm wrong David thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else